I wait in line for the bathroom every
time I'm in public
every time I'm a female so I always wait
for a typical busy bathroom women have
to wait about thirty four times as long
as men but contrary to some stereotypes
it's not because they're busy
chit-chatting or reapplying their makeup
inside so then why is there always a
line for the women's restroom women
spend as much as twice as long in the
bathroom as men and that's because they
men straight they have more layers of
clothes to remove they always have to
enter a stall and they're far more
likely to have kids or elderly people
with them but these are just
contributing factors to a much larger
problem well in most the building stock
there are fewer fixtures for women than
there are for men that's Kathryn Anthony
a professor of architecture at the
University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign it is definitely a
subtle but very powerful form of gender
discrimination no question about that it
is plain and simple there's no
disguising it she says that in many
buildings the men's and women's rooms
are the same size but because urinals
take up less space men's rooms have more
toilets which contributes to less
waiting time for men to figure out just
how much less queuing theorists at Ghent
University developed a model first they
considered bathrooms that were the same
size where men have 12 toilets and women
have just 10 then they accounted for the
time spent per bathroom visit for women
and men and the speed of traffic the
model showed that if someone arrives
every five seconds on average women will
wait for more than six minutes while men
will wait just 11 seconds so then what
would a better toilet ratio be I would
say the ratio should be well more than
one to one she's right according to this
model the women's room should have at
least 50% more toilets in the men's room
as they show here only then which men
and women have nearly equal wait times
now the u.s. is getting closer to this
target thanks to the so-called potty
parody movement it took off in 1987 when
a California State Senator went to a
Tchaikovsky concert at the Hollywood
Bowl there he waited for more than half
an hour for his wife to use the bathroom
he realized just how long it took for
her and that was unfair she complained
and he complained and said wait a minute
this isn't right
soon after he introduced a bill to the
California Senate which demanded more
toilets for women in large new public
buildings that started a wave of
legislation across some states and also
cities and municipalities at least 21
states and several cities have since
passed potty parity policies in 2005 for
example New York City passed legislation
that requires a 2 to 1 toilet ratio in
places of public assembly such as
baseball stadiums but here's the thing
even where these laws exist you still
find long lines for the women's room and
that's because they apply only to
buildings that are new for undergoing
major renovations which leaves thousands
of older buildings such as theaters with
too few toilets for women sure it's a
hassle to wait but that's not the only
problem long-term it can actually affect
your health a lot of women can end up
with urinary tract infections and other
kinds of health issues so what can be
done
aside from waiting for renovations or
new construction there's a new trend
gender-neutral bathrooms that's a way to
alleviate the problem of potty parity
altogether so either nobody waits or
everybody waits but you don't have one
group waiting more than another and
let's be real
women are already using the men's room
if the wide in the women's room is too
long I will never hesitate to go to the
men's room I probably go to the men's
room a couple times a year when it when
it's a dire situation I will literally
go in the men's bathroom probably more
than I will go in the women's bathroom
in New York I also use the men's room a
lot when I'm waiting because well we all
know the alternative is a lot worse
you
[Music]